the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right let's begin so as I mentioned
before this this this lecture will be
recorded for OCW so again in the future
lectures if you don't want to have the
back of your head show up just don't sit
in this this front area here so first of
all what a crowd you guys were finally
in 26100 sixth circle and made it big
huh so good afternoon and welcome to the
very first class of six triple one and
also six hundred the semester so my name
is Anabelle first name Anna last name
Bell I'm a lecturer in the EECS
Department and I'll be giving some of
the lectures for today along with later
on in the in the term professor Eric
Grimson who's sitting right down there
will be giving some of the lectures as
well okay so today we're going to go
over some just basic administrivia a
little bit of course information and
then we're going to talk a little bit
about what is computation so we'll
discuss at a very high level what
computers do just to make sure we're all
on the same page and then we're gonna
dive right into Python basics we're
gonna talk a little bit about
mathematical operations you can do with
Python and then we're going to talk
about Python variables and types so as I
mentioned in my introductory email all
the slides in code that I'll talk about
during lectures will be up before
lecture so I highly encourage you to
download them and to have them open
we're gonna go go through some in class
exercises which will be available on
those slides and it's it's fun to do and
it's also great if you could take notes
about on the code just so you just for
future reference it's it's true it this
is a really fast paced course and we
ramped up really quickly so we do want
to position you to succeed in this
course so as I was writing this I was
trying to think about when I was first
starting the program you know what
helped me get through my first very
first programming course and this is
really like a good list so the first
thing was I just read the piece that's
as soon as they came out made sure that
you know the terminology kind of just
sunk in and then during lectures you
know if the lecturer was talking about
something that
you know suddenly I remembered oh I saw
that word in the p-set and I didn't know
what it was well hey now I know what it
is right so just give it a read you
don't need to start it if you're new to
programming I think the key word is
practice so it's like math you know or
reading the more you practice the better
you get at it it you're not going to
absorb programming by watching me write
programs because I already know how to
program right you guys need to practice
so download the code before lector
follow along whatever I type you guys
can type and I think also one of the big
things is if you're new to programming
you're kind of afraid that you're gonna
break your computer right and you can't
really do that just by running anaconda
and typing in some commands so don't be
afraid to just type some stuff in and
see what it does
worst case you just restart the computer
right so yeah yeah so that's probably
the big thing right there I should
probably highlighted it but don't be
afraid great so this is pretty much a
road map of all of six triple one or 600
as I've just explained it so there's
three big things we want you to get out
of this course okay the first thing is
the knowledge of concepts which is
pretty much true of any class that
you'll take right the class will teach
you something through lectures exams
will test how much you know this is a
class in programming right the other
thing we need you we want you to get out
of it is programming skills and the last
thing and I think this is what makes
this class really great is we teach you
how to solve problems and we do that
through the psets
so that's really how I feel the roadmap
of this course looks like and underlying
all of these is just practice so you
have to just type some stuff away and
code a lot and you'll succeed in this
course I think okay so what are the
things we're going to learn in this
class I feel like the things we're going
to learn in this class can be divided
into basically three different sections
so the first one is
related to these first two first two
items here so it's really about learning
how to program so learning how to
program is part of it is figuring out
what what objects to create you'll learn
about these later how do you represent
knowledge with data structures that's
sort of the broad term for that and then
as you're writing programs you need to
programs aren't just veneer sometimes
programs jump around they make decisions
there's some control flow to programs so
that's what the second line is going to
be be about the second big part of this
course is a little bit more abstract and
it deals with how do you write good code
good style code that's readable so when
you write code you want to write it such
that you know you're in big company
other people will read it other people
will use it so it has to be readable and
understandable by others so to that end
you need to write code that's well
organized modular easy to understand
right and not only that not only will
your code be read by other people but
next year maybe you'll take another
course and you'll want to look back at
some of the problem sets you wrote in
this class you kind of want to be a
better re-read your code right if it's a
big mess you might not be able to
understand or we understand what you
what you were doing so writing readable
code and organizing code is also a big
part and the last section is going to
deal with so the first two are actually
part of the programming in introduction
to programming and computer science and
python and the last one deals a little
bit it deals mostly with the computer
science part in introduction to
programming and computer science and
python so we're going to talk about once
you've learned how to write programs in
Python how do you compare programs in
Python how do you know that one program
is better than the other right how do
you know that one program is more
efficient than the other how do you know
that one algorithm is is better than the
other so that's what we're going to talk
about in the last part of the course ok
so that's all for the sort of
administration part of the course so
let's let's
start by talking a little at a high
level what does the computer do so
fundamentally it does two things one
performs calculation and it performs a
lot of calculations right computers
these days are really really fast a
billion calculations per second is
probably not not far off it performs
these calculations and it has to store
them somewhere right stores them in
computer memory so computer also has to
remember results and these days it's not
uncommon to find computers with hundreds
of gigabytes of storage so the kinds of
calculations that computers do there are
two kinds so one are calculations that
are built into the language so these are
the very low level x types of
calculations things like addition
subtraction multiplication and so on and
once you have a language that has these
sort of primitive calculate calculation
types you as a programmer can put these
types together and then define your own
calculations okay and then create new x
types of calculations and the computer
will be able to perform those as well
okay and I think one thing I want to
stress and we're going to come back to
this in this this again during during
this entire lecture actually is
computers only know what you tell them
okay computers only do what you tell
them to do they're not magical they
don't have a mind they just know how to
perform calculations really really
quickly but you have to tell them how
what what calculations to do okay okay
computers don't know anything all right
we've come to that
so let's let's go into the types of
knowledge okay the first type of
knowledge is declarative knowledge and
those are things like statements of fact
okay and this is where my email came
into play if you read it all the way to
the bottom you would have entered a
raffle
okay so a statement of fact for today's
lecture is someone will win a prize
before class ends and the prize was a
Google cardboard right
Google's state-of-the-art virtual
reality glasses and I have them right
here
okay yeah okay
I delivered on my promise okay so that's
a statement of fact but if you so
pretend I'm a machine okay I don't know
anything except what you tell me what
you tell me so I don't know I know that
you tell me this statement I'm like okay
but how is someone gonna win a Google
cardboard before class ends right that's
where imperative knowledge comes in so
imperative knowledge is the recipe or
the how-to or the sequence of steps okay
sorry that's just my funny for that one
so the sequence of steps is is the
imperative is imperative knowledge so if
I'm a machine you need to tell me how
that someone will win a Google cardboard
before class right so if I follow these
steps then technically I should I should
reach a conclusion okay so step one I
think we've already done that who ever
wanted to sign up had signed up so now
I'm going to open my IDE so I'm just
basically being a machine and following
the steps that you've taken that you've
told me so the IDE that we're using in
this class is called anaconda I'm just
scroll down to the bottom okay hopefully
even started in promise at zero so I've
opened my IDE I'm gonna follow the next
set of instructions I'm gonna choose a
random number between the first and the
enth responder okay now I'm gonna
actually use Python to do this and this
is also an example of how just like a
really simple task in your life you can
use computers or programming to do that
because if I chose a random number
might be biased because for example I
might like the number eight so to choose
a random number
I'm going to go and say okay where's the
list of responders it starts at 15
actually it starts at 16 because that's
me okay so we're gonna choose a random
number between 16 and the end person to
66
oh we just got up okay - okay I'm gonna
cut it off right here at 271 okay 69 to
71 perfect okay so I'm gonna choose a
random number so I'm gonna go to my ID
and you don't need to know how to do
this yet but by the end of this class
you will so I'm just gonna use Python
I'm just gonna get the random number
package that's gonna get me a random
number so I'm gonna say random dot R and
int and I'm going to choose a random
number between 16 and 272 okay
75 okay great so I chose a random number
and I'm gonna find the number in the
responders sheet what was the number
again sorry 75 okay up we go there we go
Lauren CoV yeah nice you're here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
awesome alright so that's an example of
me being a machine right and also at the
same time using Python in just my
everyday life right just lecturing just
to find a random number right so just
you know try to use Python wherever you
can and that just gives you practice
okay so that was fun but right on my
team we're MIT students right and we
love numbers here at MIT right so here's
a numerical example for that shows the
difference between declarative and
imperative knowledge so I want to find
the square root of so an example of
declarative knowledge is the square root
of a number X is y such that Y times y
is equal to X okay that's just a
statement of fact it's true imperative
not so computers don't know what to do
with that right they don't know what to
do with that statement but computers do
know how to follow a recipe so here's a
well-known algorithm to find the square
root of a number X let's say X is
originally 16 so if a computer follows
this this algorithm it's going to start
with a guess gee let's say 3 right we're
trying to find the spirit of 16 we're
gonna calculate G times G is 9 right and
we're gonna ask is if G times G is close
enough to X and stop and say G is the
answer I'm not really happy with 9 being
really close to 16 right so I'm going to
say I'm not I'm not stopping here I'm
gonna keep going ok so if it's not close
enough then I'm gonna make a new guest
biabbering G averaging G and x over G so
that's x over G here and that's the
average over there and the new average
is going to be my new guess
okay and that's what it says and then
the last step is using the new guess
repeat the process so then we go back to
the beginning and repeat the whole
process over and over again okay and
that's what the rest of the rows does
and you keep doing this until you decide
that you're close enough okay so then so
what we saw for the imperative knowledge
in the previous numerical example was
the recipe right for how to find the
square root of x so what were the three
parts to the recipe one was a simple
sequence of steps right there were four
steps pretty much the other was a flow
of control so there were parts where we
made decisions right are we close enough
there were parts where we repeated some
steps so at the end we said repeat steps
one two three so that's the flow of
control and the last part of the recipe
was a way to stop right you don't want a
program that keeps going and going or
for a recipe you don't want to keep
baking bread forever right you want to
stop at some point like ten breads a
xena right okay so you have to have a
way of stopping okay and this in the
previous example the way of stopping was
that we decided we were close enough
close enough was maybe B being within
point zero one point zero zero zero one
whatever you pick so this recipe is
there for an algorithm right if your
science speak it's gonna be an algorithm
okay and that's what we're gonna learn
about in this class okay so we're
dealing with computers and we actually
want to capture a recipe inside a
computer computer of being a mechanical
process and historically there were two
ways of there were there were two two
ways of sorry historically there were
two different types of computers okay so
originally there were these things
called six program computers and I'm old
enough to have used something like this
where there's just numbers and plus
minus multiplication divided and equal
but calculators these days are a lot
more complicated but way back then a
fix-up an example of a fixed program
computers is
it only knows how to do addition
multiplication subtraction division if
you want to plot something you can't if
you want to go on the internet check you
know said email with it you can't it can
only do this one thing okay and if you
wanted to create a machine that did
another thing then you'd have to create
another fixed-program computers that did
a completely separate task okay so
that's not very great right so that's
when stored-program computers came into
play and these were machines that could
store a sequence of instructions and
these machines could execute the
sequence of instructions and you could
change the sequence of instructions and
execute a different see this different
sequence of instructions so you could do
different tasks in the same machine
right and that's the computer as we know
it these days
so the central processing unit is is
where you know all of these decisions
get made and these are all the sort of
peripherals so the basic machine
architecture so at the heart of every
computer there's just this this basic
architecture and it contains I guess
four main parts over the first is the
memory input and output is the other one
the ALU is where all of the operations
are done and the operations that the ALU
can do are these really primitive
operations and subtraction and so on so
what the memory contains is a bunch of
data and your sequence of instructions
okay
so interacting with the arithmetic logic
unit is the control unit and the control
unit contains one program counter so
when you load a sequence of instructions
the program counter starts at the first
sequence it gets what the FIR starts at
the at the sequence at the first
instruction it gets what the instruction
is and it sends it to the ALU the ALU
asks what are we what what are we doing
operations on here what's happening so
it might get some data you know if
you're adding two numbers it might get
two numbers from from memory it might do
some operations and it might store data
back into memory okay and after it's
done the ALU is going to go back and the
program counter is going to increase by
one which means that we're going to go
to the next sequence in the instruction
set okay and it just goes linearly like
instruction by instruction there might
be one instrument particular instruction
that does some sort of test it's gonna
say is is this particular is this
particular value greater or equal to or
the same as this other particular value
so that's a test an example of a test
and the test is going to be either
either return something either return
true or false and depending on the
result of of that test you might either
go to the next instruction or you might
set the program counter to go all the
way back to the beginning and so on so
you're not just sort of linearly
stepping through all the instructions
there might be some control flow
involved where you might skip an
instruction or start from the beginning
or so on and after you're done when when
when you finished executing the last
instruction then you might output
something so that's really the basic the
basic way that a computer works okay so
just to recap you have the stored
program computer that contains these
sequences of instructions the primitive
operations that it can do our addition
subtraction logic operations tests which
are you know something equal to
something else something less than and
so on and
data storing data moving data around and
things like that and the interpreter
goes through every instructions every
instruction and decides whether you're
going to go to the next instruction skip
instructions or repeat instructions and
so on okay so we've talked about
primitives and in fact the Alan Turing
was a really great computer scientist he
showed that you can compute anything
using the six primitives and the six
primitives were our move left move right
read/write scan and do nothing okay so
using those six those six instructions
and the piece of tape he showed that you
could compute anything and using those
six instructions programming languages
came about that created a more
convenient set of primitives so you
don't have to program in only these only
these six commands right and one
interesting thing or one really
important thing that came about from
this from these six primitives is that
if you can compute something in Python
let's say if you write a program that
computes something in Python then in
theory you can come you can write a
program that computes the exact same
thing in any other language okay and
that's a really powerful statement okay
think about that today when you review
your slides think about that again and
that's really powerful okay so once you
set have your set of primitives you can
set of primitives for a particular
language okay you can start creating
expressions and these expressions are
going to be combinations of of the
primitives in the programming language
and the expressions are going to have
some value and they're gonna have some
meaning in in the programming language
okay so let's do a little bit of a
parallel with English just so you see
what I'm what I mean
so in English the primitive constructs
are going to be words okay there's a lot
of words in the English language
programming is in Python there are there
are primitives but there
many of them so there's there are floats
boolean's you know these are numbers
strings and simple operators like
addition subtraction and so on
okay so we have primitive constructs
using these primitive constructs we can
start creating in English phrases write
sentences and the same in programming
languages so in English we can say
something like cat dog boy okay that we
say is not syntactically valid so that's
bad syntax right I that's now now noun
that doesn't make sense
what does have good syntax in English is
noun verb noun so cat hugs boy is
syntactically valid similarly in a
programming language something like this
in Python in this case a word and then
the number five doesn't really make
sense it's not syntactically valid but
something like operator operand operator
is okay so once you've created these
these phrases or these these expressions
that are syntactically valid you have to
think about the static semantics of your
phrase okay of your expression so so for
example in English I are hungry is good
syntax okay but it's kind of weird to
say right we have a pronoun of urban
adjectives later which doesn't really
make sense
right I am hungry this is better so this
is statically semantic this does not
have good static semantics similarly in
programming languages and you'll get the
hang of this hang of this the more you
do it something like this three point
two times five is okay but what does it
mean right what's the meaning to have a
word added to the number to a number
there's no meaning behind that right its
syntax is okay because you have operator
operand operator but it doesn't really
make sense to add a number to a word for
example okay
so once you have created these
expressions that are syntactically
correct and static semantically correct
in English for example you think about
the semantics so what's the meaning of
the phrase and in English you can
actually have more than one meaning to
an entire phrase okay so in this case
flying planes are dangerous or flying
planes can be dangerous can have two
meanings is the act of flying a plane is
dangerous or the plane that is in the
air is dangerous right and this might be
a cuter example this reading-lamp hasn't
uttered a word since I bought it what's
going on right so that has two meanings
right it's playing on the word
reading-lamp in programming so that's
that's an English in English you can
have a sentence that has more than one
meaning
that's syntactically correct and static
semantically correct but in programming
languages the program that you write a
set of instructions that you write only
has one meaning so remember we're coming
back to the fact that the computer only
does what you tell it to do okay it's
not going to suddenly you know decide to
add another variable for some reason
it's just going to execute whatever
statements you've put up okay so in
programming languages there's only one
meaning but the problem comes the
problem that comes into play in
programming languages is it's not the
meaning that you might have intended as
the programmer okay so that's where
things can go wrong and there's gonna be
a lecture on debugging a little bit
later in the course but this is here
just to just to tell you that if you see
an error pop up in your program it's
just you know some text that says error
notes some for example if we do
something like this
this isn't actively correct incorrect
syntactically incorrect see there's some
angry text right here right like what is
going on the more you program the more
you'll get the hang of reading these
errors but this is basically telling me
this this the line that I wrote is
syntactically incorrect okay and it's
pointing me to the exact line and says
this is wrong so I can go back and fix
it as a programmer
okay so syntax errors are actually
really easily caught by Python static
semantic errors so that was an example
of a syntax error static semantic errors
can also be caught by Python as long as
if if your program has some decisions to
make as long as you've gone down the
branch where this where the static
semantic error happens and this is
probably gonna be the most frustrating
one especially as you're starting out
the program might do something different
than what you expected it to do right
and that's not because the program
suddenly you know for example you
expected the program to give you an
output of zero for a certain test case
and the output that you got was 10 right
well the program didn't suddenly decide
to change its answer to ten it just did
executed the program that you that you
wrote right so that's the case where the
program gave you a different answer than
expected programs might crash which
means they stopped running that's okay
just go back to your code and figure out
what was wrong and another example of
different meaning than what you intended
was maybe the program will stop it's
also okay there are ways to stop it
besides restarting the computer okay so
then Python programs are going to be
sequences of definitions and commands
we're gonna have expressions that are
going to be evaluated okay and commands
that that tell the interpreter to do
something
so if you've done problem set zero
you'll see that you can type commands
directly in the shell here which is the
part on the right where I did some some
really simple things two plus four or
you can type commands up in here on the
left hand side and then run your program
okay
notice that well we'll talk about this I
won't talk about this now but these are
on the right hand side typically you
write very simple commands just if
you're testing something out and on the
left hand side here in the editor you
write more lines and more complicated
programs okay so now we're going to
start talking about Python and in Python
we're gonna come back to this everything
is an object and python programs
manipulate these data objects all
objects in Python are going to have a
type and the type is going to tell
python the kinds of operations that you
can do on these objects so if an object
is the number five for example you can
add the number to another number
subtract the number take it to the power
of something and so on more as a more
general example for example I am a human
so that's my type and I can walk speak
English etc Chewbacca is going to be a
type Wookiee right so we can walk do
that sound that I can't do right so he
can do that but I can't I'm not even
gonna try and and so on okay so once you
have these Python objects everything is
an object in Python there are actually
two types of objects one are scalar
object so that means these are very
basic objects in Python from which
everything can be can be made okay so
these are scalar objects they can't be
subdivided the other type of object is a
non scalar object and these are objects
that have some internal structure so for
example the number five is a scalar
object because it can't be subdivided
but a list of numbers for example five
six seven eight is going to be a non
scalar object
because I'm divided so you just can
subdivide it into you can find parts
parts to it it's it's made up of a
sequence of numbers right so here's the
list of all of the scalar objects in
Python we have integers for example all
of the whole numbers
floats which are all of the decimal real
numbers anything with a decimal bulls
our boolean z' there's only two values
two boolean's that's true and false note
the capitalization capital T and capital
F and this other thing called none type
it's special it has only one value
called none and it represents the
absence of a type and it sometimes comes
in handy for for some programs if you
want to find the type of an object you
can use this special command called type
and then in the parentheses you put down
what you want to find the type of okay
so you can write into the shell type of
five and the shell will tell you that's
an integer okay if you happen to want to
convert between two different types
Python allows you to do that and to do
that you use this you put the type that
you want to convert to right before the
object that you want to convert to so
float three will convert the integer
three to the float 3.0 and similarly you
can convert any float into an integer
and converting to an integer just
truncates so it just takes away the
decimal and whatever's after it it does
not round and keeps just the integer
part okay so for this slide I'm going to
talk about it but if you'd like go to if
you have the slides up go to go to this
exercise and after I'm done talking
about the slide we'll see we'll see what
people think for that exercise okay so
one of the most important things that
you can do in program in basically any
programming and pythons also is to print
things out so printing out is how you
you interact with the user okay so to
print things out you use the print
command so if you're in the shell if you
simply type 3 + 2 you do see a value
here 5 right but that's not actually
printing something out and that becomes
apparent when when you actually type
things into the editor so if you just do
3 plus 2 and you run the program that's
this little green button here you see on
the right-hand side here it ran my
program but it didn't actually print
anything if you type this into the
console it does show you this value but
that's just sort of a like peeking into
the value for you as just for you as a
programmer okay it's not actually
printing it out to anyone if you want to
print something now you have to use the
print State print print statement like
that so in this case this is actually
going to print this number 5 to the
console okay so that's basically my set
so out just tells you it's an
interaction within the shell only it's
not interacting with with anyone else
and if you don't have any how that means
it got printed out to the console
alright so we talked a little bit about
objects once you have objects you can
combine objects and operators to form
these expressions and each expression is
going to have value so an expression
evaluates to a value and the syntax for
an expression is going to be object
operator object like that and these are
some operate operators you can do on
instant floats so there's the typical
ones addition subtraction multiplication
and division if for the first three you
have the answer that you get the type of
the answer that you get is going to
depend on the type of your variables so
if both of the variables of the opéra
operands are integers then the result
you're going to get is of type integer
but if at least one of them is a float
than the result you're gonna get as a
float divisions a little bit special in
that no matter what the operands it are
the result is always going to be a float
okay the other upper operations you can
do in these these are these are also
useful is our the remainder so the % if
you use the % between two operands
that's going to give you the remainder
when you divide I by J and raising
something to the power of something else
is using the star star operator and I
star stars J is going to take I to the
power of J so these operations have the
typical precedence that you might expect
in math for example and if you'd like to
put precedence toward some other
operations you can use parentheses to do
that
yeah all right
okay so we have ways of creating
expressions and we have operations we
can do on on objects but what's going to
be useful is to be able to save values
to some name and the name is going to be
something that you can you pick and it
should be a descriptive name and when
you save the value to a name you're
going to be able to access that value
later on in your program okay and that's
very useful so to save a value to a to a
variable to a variable name use the
equal sign okay and the equal sign is
the assign is an assignment so it
assigns the right-hand side which is a
value to the left-hand side which is
going to be a variable name so in this
case I signed the float 3.14159 to the
vet to the variable pi and in the second
line I'm going to take this expression
22 divided by 7 I'm going to evaluate it
it's going to come up with some some
decimal number and I'm gonna save it
into the variable PI underscore aprox
okay values are stored in memory and
this assignment in Python we say the
assignment binds the name to the value
so when you when you use that name later
on in your program you're going to be
referring you're going to be referring
to the value in memory okay and if you
ever want to refer to the value later on
in your code you just simply type the
name of the variable that you that
you've assigned it to okay so why do we
want to give names to the two
expressions well you want to reuse the
names right instead of a values and it
makes your code look a lot nicer so this
is a piece of code that calculates the
area of a circle and notice I've
assigned a variable pi to 3.14159 I've
assigned another variable called radius
to be 2.2 and then later on in my code I
have another line that's his area this
is another variable is equal to this is
an assignment
to this expression and this expression
is just going to is is referring to
these variable names PI and radius and
it's going to look them up their values
in memory and it's going to replace
their value their these variable names
with those values and it's going to do
the calculation for me and in the end
this whole expression is going to be
replaced by one number and that's gonna
be the float okay here's another
exercise while I'm talking about this
slide I do want to make a note about
programming versus math okay so in math
you're often presented with with was
sort of a problem that's a software
solve for X X plus y is equal to
something something solve for X for
example okay that's coming back to the
fact that program computers can't don't
know what to do with that computers need
to be told what to do
so in programming if you want to solve
for X you need to tell the computer
exactly how to solve for X you need to
figure out what formula you need to give
the computer in order to be able to
solve for X okay so that means always in
programming the right-hand side is going
to be an expression it's something
that's going to be evaluated to a value
and the left-hand side is always a
variable so it's going to be an
assignment so the equal sign is not is
not like an in math right where you can
have thing a lot of things to the left
and a lot of things to the right of the
equal sign there's only one thing to the
left of the equal sign and that's gonna
be a variable an equal sign stands for
an assignment once we've created
expressions and we have these these
assignments you can rebind variable
names using new assignment statements
okay so let's look at an example for
that let's say this is our memory okay
let's look at let's type back in the
example with finding the radius okay so
let's say pi is equal to 3.14
okay so in memory we're going to create
this value 3.14 we're going to bind it
to the variable name pi
next line radius is equal to two point
two in memory we're creating this
variable of this value two point two and
we're gonna bind it to the vet to the
variable name pipe radius okay then we
have this expression here it's going to
substitute the values for pi from memory
and the value for radius from memory
it's gonna calculate this this this
about the value that this expression
evaluates to it's gonna pop that into
the memory and it's going to assign
because we're using the equal sign it's
gonna assign that value to that variable
area okay so now let's say we rebind the
vat we rebind
radius to be something else so radius is
already in is being is being is is bound
to the value 2.2 but when we do this
line radius is equal to radius plus 1
we're going to take away the binding to
2.2 we're going to make do this
calculation the new value is 3.2 and
we're going to bind that rebind that
that value to that to that same variable
so in memory notice we're still going to
have this this value 2.2 floating around
but we've lost sort of the handle for it
okay there's no way to get it back so
it's kind of just in memory sitting
there at some point it might get
collected by what they what we call the
garbage collector in Python it'll
retrieve these sort of lost values and
then reuse them for new values and
things like that but radius now points
to the new value okay so we can never
get back to point 2
and that's it okay the value of area
notice this is very important the value
of area did not change okay and it did
not change because these are all the
instructions we told the computer to do
okay we told we just told it to change
radius to be radius plus one we never
told it to recalculate the value of area
if I copied that line down here then the
value of area would change but we never
told it to do that right so the computer
only does what we tell it to do that's
the last thing next lecture we're going
to talk about adding control flow to our
programs so how do you tell the computer
to do one thing or another all right